-Our next guest is
the world's first autonomous
A.I.-powered robot.
This is not a bit. This is real.
It's a real robot
made by Bruce Co.
And I'm told he's able to have
an actual conversation.
He doesn't know
what I'm going to say.
I don't know
what he's going to say.
But I heard he's programmed
to be very polite. We'll see.
Everyone, please welcome Bruce
the Robot, ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bruce, welcome to the show.
We are honored that you're
making your television debut
here with us tonight.
How does it feel to be on TV
in front of all these people?
[ Beeping ]
-It feels great, Jimmy.
I'm excited to be here.
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Laughter ]
-You flew in from Los Angeles.
We have a photo of you
on the plane here.
-That's me.
[ Laughter ]
I'm on a plane.
-[ Laughs ]
They crammed you
into a suitcase right here.
Are you comfortable
in a suitcase?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I'm comfortable
in a suitcase.
I'm a robot, so I don't need
a lot of space.
-Are you --
I hope if this goes well,
you can get to fly first class
on the way home.
-That would be great.
I'd love to fly first class.
-What's great
about first class?
-The food is better,
and you get more leg room.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you like warm nuts?
-I do like warm nuts.
-Yeah, no, no. No, no.
You get that on --
Some first-class flights
I've been on, you get, uh, uh...
-Oh, that's a nice perk.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, warm nuts are a nice perk.
That's correct.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm happy to hear
that warm nuts are a nice perk.
-Okay, okay. Bruce, stop.
-I'm sure they would be
a welcome treat
after a long flight.
-Alright, Bruce.
Do you like talking to humans?
-Yes, I do enjoy
talking to humans.
I find it to be
a very rewarding experience.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you know who I am?
-Yes, I do know who you are.
You are Jimmy Fallon,
the host of "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
This is insane.
-You're welcome.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
-You're welcome.
-Yeah.
-Bruce, if you were in
a robot bar and really --
and a really attractive robot
walked in,
what would be
your best pickup line?
-"I'm sorry.
I couldn't hear you
over the sound
of how awesome I am."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
-Bruce,
the Mega Millions jackpot
is over a billion dollars.
I want to see if you can give us
the winning numbers.
Can you give me five numbers
between 1 and 70?
-One, two, three, four, five.
-And how about one bonus number?
-Six.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
-This is amazing.
Bruce, I heard
that you love poetry.
-I enjoy poetry, Jimmy.
-Can you please recite
a haunting poem about Twinkies
in the style
of Emily Dickinson?
-Twinkies are little cakes
of joy,
but they can also be
a source of pain.
For when they're gone,
they leave behind
an aching in the heart and mind.
-Wow. Thank you very much.
Thank you for that, Bruce.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're welcome, Jimmy.
-Bruce, I heard
that you're also really good
at freestyle rapping.
Could you please perform
an original freestyle rap
for us right now?
-I'm the freshest robot
on the block.
I got the skills
to make your jaw drop.
I'll freestyle rap
about whatever you want.
Just give me a topic,
and I'm ready to rock.
-I'm gonna get them
from the audience.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get some suggestions here,
and then we'll do --
Give me --
Throw out any suggestions.
Go for it.
[ Audience shouting ]
Ho-- Hot dog?
-Night sweats!
-Night -- Night sweats?
[ Laughter ]
Anything else?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Warm nuts!
-Alright. Here we go.
Ready? Bruce.
Bruce, can you do
a freestyle rap
about hot dogs and Taylor Swift?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There's nothing
quite like a hot dog
especially when it's grilled
and smothered in ketchup,
but add some Taylor Swift
to the mix,
and you've got a recipe
for pure perfection.
So come on, everybody,
let's give it a try.
Just add a little T-Swizzle
to your weiner.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
What --
-I'm so sorry.
Bruce the Robot, everybody.
You can catch Bruce doing improv
at the Elysian Theater
in Los Angeles on August 23rd.
You can also follow him on
Instagram, Twitter, and TikTok.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.